[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talk about
what we want [ __ ]
in the house hi cat hi joe
welcome to the show thank you very much
for the hawaiian story you were talking
about the hawaiian story joe you were
still you guys are laughing about a
hawaiian store
video if you guys know that i'm a
down-ass homie
because when i'm tasked to do [ __ ] i
[ __ ] do it a thousand right
so like my homie nancy she's getting she
was getting married in hawaii
and then she was like all right check it
out joe what is the most
best vlogging camera would you would
recommend and i'm like oh i don't know
like maybe
like this one i just use a gopro and
she's like yeah she's like i'm
you know it's 4 000 for a videographer
so i think i'm gonna vlog
or something like that and i'm like
you're gonna vlog your wedding that is
so [ __ ] weird
and she goes yeah um and i'm like nah
just give me the [ __ ]
camera i'm gonna do it yeah cause i was
like
if you just need me to hold the gopro
[ __ ] do it you know
and then they watch their wedding video
and it's all joe just going hey
no actually joe killed it so we were all
shocked so we were really surprised
because he was actually like doing the
best he could
like the best job he could it was really
endearing to watch because
like he was like running like trying to
catch shots and he was just like
like uh give me a stick here's this
he'd be like like really like into it
like trying to get and then he was funny
with the gopro yeah you know how hard it
is to get a [ __ ] actual like frame
like how clo like it's so [ __ ] far
right so like if they're here he was
like
he was like this they're here right so
like
i'm like crouching down not trying to
beat him it's like a fear
like a blanket so funny so like any time
we were trying to
capture um we're trying to capture like
the moment right you always see joe with
the [ __ ] stick and the gopro tiny
little gopro at the end of the stick
just right there and it was just the
funniest thing ever like casey david and
i
could not stop laughing and i had a
fanny pack full of the
batteries and equipment and i was just
like
[Laughter]
dude i'm gonna show you some photos
casey and david was how come they didn't
ask casey or david he offered
he offered he set himself up for that
job for the day and it was the funniest
thing ever i was watching through
david's instagram and his stories
and like when joe's doing something and
he's focused
he's nothing else in the world matters
that's awesome he's just honed in so
they're they're off their altar
but you zoom in oh yeah like
that i love that he also has like a
covet safe mask
that's [ __ ] funny he did great though
this is why you and nikki are very
similar because my
brother-in-law was getting shotgun
married and
it was very low budget they literally
just got married in a santa barbara park
and nikki was tasked with like hey is it
okay if you take a couple of pictures
please don't take too many it's okay and
this [ __ ] took 3
000 [ __ ] pictures she had them do
like so many different poses that i was
like this is unnatural
this isn't people don't pose like this
she's really good though
she loves it but you guys are very
similar this way where you're tasked
with something and you're gonna [ __ ]
do it to the end
to the bone no but the funniest part i
think for us
that was very entertaining was that in
the beginning of the day the beginning
of the ceremony he was like so into it
he's like yeah
and then slowly throughout the day his
enthusiasm just trickled down
so by the end of the night he was just
like he's like wrap
it up wrap it up we're good he's like
how long is his [ __ ] wedding dude
did you end up giving her all the
footage and stuff yeah like i was like
it was her gopro but i feel like my
heart was like i'm [ __ ] over this
[ __ ] and then it's like wait that's a
[ __ ] moment right there [ __ ]
i gotta record this [ __ ] one night
it was too good man but you did i from
what i saw like you did great because he
was a bad we're about to do the bouquet
toss she was like
legit yeah like he was in the middle of
eating and they were like oh yeah we're
about to do the bouquet tops he's like
[ __ ] all right that's cute he's [ __ ]
cute
you're the best joe they were doing a
whole bunch of toasts
like a lot of speeches and isaac was
sitting next to joe
and so isaac had a better like vantage
point of the speeches so then he's like
here isaac here
just take it here i was like dude just
do it
you just could set it on the the chair i
was just like hold it like this and then
isaac was like holding it and i'm like
all right cool and i can eat my chicken
meanwhile your friend is like it's fine
you can stop now
yeah she told me that i'm like no no no
no no no no no
we're not doing it that way we're doing
this through yeah tonight wedding night
we're going in the bedroom we're getting
it live we're making an erotic version
of this
yeah oh my god i'm coming to your
honeymoon
we're doing this right it was the best
and then during the bouquet house too or
not the bouquet sauce but the
the groom thing yeah that was so funny
because this
pretend that she's a little kid okay a
little boy because it was open to all
men like you didn't have to be
just single um and then so this little
boy was standing right there and then
like i'm the dude
he ends up like catching it right in
front of his face and he was like this
was like this he was about to catch it
wait joe did
no no i was capturing it another guy
ends up catching the garter
right in front of a little kid's face
and the little kid starts crying oh
he was crying because he wanted to catch
up he should lose he's not
getting married next yeah no but the
price so there were prizes instead of
like getting married next thing so like
for example
i caught the bouquet because it was open
to every everyone and i ended up getting
a purse
but like for the little kid he was gonna
get like a hundred dollar visa card or
something
so he was like i i don't do he end up
giving it to him yeah
i don't remember he shouldn't [ __ ] up
dude he snoozy lose bro that was funny
because the rest of the night they were
like oh
this guy he's gonna remember it forever
dude did i tell you guys the story of
when i need a kid in the balls for the
garter toss
[Laughter]
are you that competitive that you would
need a
unfortunately so i was like 15 years old
i'm at this wedding it's my uncle's
wedding and
i was like uh my my uncle's like hey
like that's the table for the champagne
that's the table for the sparkling cider
and i was like great so i went to the
table for the
sparkling sun or didn't want to drink
anything at all so i go i pick up some
of that
and i drink it and i'm like this doesn't
taste very good
but okay i guess it was a wrong table it
was a switched it was a switch thing
but then i swear then i kept on drinking
the sparkling cider from this table and
i
and then they do the garter toss and i'm
like [ __ ]
hyped now i'm like i'm like [ __ ] get
this stuff i'm gonna get this goddamn
thing right
and so then it's it's almost like the
thing goes up in the air
i look around me and i'm like threat
assessment i see this [ __ ] kid next
to me who's like two steps ahead
i grab him by the back of the neck and i
[ __ ] knee him in the balls
no you did not i did i swear to god [ __ ]
i thought it was by accident this kid
goes down
and then you grab it i'm 16 years old
and i'm intoxicated but i don't know
that i am
oh my god yeah then then uh yeah then i
[ __ ]
grab it and they actually because of
foul play i had to do a re-do
[Laughter]
because everybody saw me do that were
they cracking up well they didn't
realize
and then i was like i was hap i was like
they're like what's going on what the
[ __ ] is up with the dude
with you steve what's going on and i was
like oh i was having [ __ ] i was having
this smell
on your breath i was having this cider i
was having sparkling cider and they're
like
no this is not this isn't right where
would you go for this and i pointed at
the table my uncle pointed at
and it was the [ __ ] that's when i
realized it's so
funny dude crazy but i had this
competitive spark i've never had i was
like aggressive drunk is that it not
even
i just i just wanted to win this because
i'm a romantic oh you wanted to get
married i wanted to have
i wanted yeah you wanted to be the next
person married i always that's the goal
of having my wife by the time i was 18
or whatever really oh yeah
oh that's sweet but it's stupid so i
need a kid in the ball it wasn't the
prize
it was the desperation to get married
that was the
that was what you wanted i wanted my
lady i wanted him
so you thought the garter will get you
the woman i need him so hard he had his
testicles removed
no i'm kidding that's what he gets for
being i actually don't even think i hit
him in the balls honestly like he was
fine
but that's so much movement
grounded by the back of the neck boom
that's like that
yeah that's an efficient movement
instead of just like going
that's a lot of honestly i didn't really
name him in the balls i basically just
just threw him in the ground that was
but it's way better steve was doing muay
thai before it was cool you know he was
throwing kids to the ground no i didn't
i don't know muay thai only only drunken
master
yeah that's what it is thank you hello
everybody
today's video is brought to you by
curology so if you're anything
like me and you never got into this like
whole skincare routine thing
and you thought it was silly and you
were just lazy because
for me i just didn't want to get through
this whole thing where i have to
research what is the best thing for me i
don't know there's so many different
kinds of soap
so i just when i showered i would like
wash my hair and then i would let it
drip to my face and i would wash my face
not curiously
that was my skincare routine yeah head
face and shoulders
but with curology it's a super simple
way
of having beautiful skin like this
with a very very awesome program and
it's really cool what i really like
about it is that everything ships right
to your door and you get your first 30
days for free you have to pay five bucks
for the shipping and handling so it
makes it
really simple because you know when you
go to supermarket yeah there is a ton of
choices and like do i get this one
or this one and these two look kind of
the same i don't know what the hell that
happens
and it's a whole month yeah for free
baby and the sign up process is super
easy you just go on their site
and then there's a licensed provider
that kind of reviews your goals and what
you want like
i don't want acne or i don't want to age
or i want to do this or that
and then they look at that and then they
create a formula that's custom
to you like me i get a dry skin so i was
like yo keep me moisturized
release me please i have the opposite
problem i need to degrease me please
and they got that too yeah so one thing
that i really like about it is
the simplicity like they took the
thinking
out of the equation and they made it so
simple for me now
there's a face wash in there i do that
in the shower
and after i get out there is my formula
that is customized to me
put that on and i got the moisturizer to
keep it soft
boom and i go to sleep nice and that's
how i stay
very beautiful when you wake up it's
perfect
that's awesome if you want perfect skin
like joe go to curology.com
off the record to get your free 30-day
trial you can try it out for a whole
month which is freaking awesome because
you see all kinds of changes
in your beautiful skin you just have to
pay for shipping and handling that's
curology.com
off the record o-f-f-t-h-e-r-e-c-o
thank you curology i feel like girls are
usually aggressive with the
bouquet yeah they take that like i want
to get married next so
like it's so adamantly different really
it signifies anything
no of course not it's so stupid that's
right but when you're that age and like
you know you're listening to stupid
angsty music and [ __ ] you know it's
funny though
i was so evidence i was so competitive
during the bridal shower because i went
to the bridal shower and like they had
all these little
games that you get to win did the jk
party come out
it totally [ __ ] came out or they're
like yo it's just a game tip what the
[ __ ]
she's like i'm never doing mafia again
no it was so funny because one of the
games where
it was kind of like the tic-tac-toe kind
of thing or like a bingo kind of thing
where
each box had something that nancy would
do and that but you can't tell her what
the boxes are you just gotta get her to
do things or
see if it comes out like for example
talk about her engagement ring or like
tie her hair up or say
no or things like that right so all
these other girls on the table they were
just like
eating their food just having a good
time and i was just like
so nancy i haven't seen your ring can i
see your ring and i get her to show me
her engagement ring
i was like oh you keep getting your food
and your like your hair and your food
here you can have my hair tie i got her
to tie up her hair
wow i was [ __ ] competitive i'm like
i'm looking like a con
artist i'm like i'm winning this [ __ ]
and then so because it was like a bingo
thing
um this other girl at the end of the
table ended up winning first
but uh i i didn't know at that moment
but then
it ended up being three gifts like three
winners and it was like the same gift
but i didn't know that at the time so my
real competitive section i was like
i was like you better share that prize
with me because i got you all those
boxes i told you to do all these
husbands it was being annoying and then
also i was drinking i'm so proud of you
yeah
you learned all those through the years
of jk party
dude old tip would have never done that
[ __ ] you were a [ __ ] haggler
so then the girl was like yeah cher
don't worry but but it was a bar
soap and it smelled really good but
anyway so then i got second place
and then because i won second place and
i was like oh cool it's the same gift
well i want to help the other girls win
so then i kept getting her like
oh how do you call because we all we got
to wear these like crown lace and then
one of the boxes was to get her to say
something in hawaiian so i'm like
what are these called again and i'm
trying to get her to do all the [ __ ] but
then she caught on and i was like
i was trying to i actually helped the
the third girl win too and i was like
[ __ ] yeah jiggy party came and clutch
and then i won the second prize too
because it was like trying to figure out
um like don't invite that girl a lot of
seconds in the story i don't know if i
would have told a second place story
no no i won the second game but first
place
i got first place in the second game not
first your last racer
this is not good second is worse than
being last yeah that's all foul play
first stories facial mess and a bar of
soap and i got a kate spade purse
you cleaned up huh i did the bar soap
smelled good that's what she said
but it was really fun though but yeah
did you need anybody in the balls
for that one of those gifts no i'm in
the ovaries
i'm not that rude i took it back
but i enjoyed the first part of it more
yeah
usually i don't like weddings and the
food is horrible but this
was [ __ ] they had a ramen bar
i got a ramen bar they had new york
strip steak that was
very soft very very having ramen and
then dancing
oh yeah nobody was dancing nobody was
that everyone was small you're not dead
yeah eating and chilling oh yeah no one
was doing it no one was dancing was it
outdoors was it pretty tired no because
the dance floor was the size of this
table because it was like really
small was dancing she did something his
size at the table that's [ __ ] up
it was just like their first dance and
for her to do like the hula dance nah
you gotta let everyone dance
nah everyone was eating it's hawaii
we're
chillin yeah i had a protest at my my
nicki's cousin's wedding because
they took so [ __ ] long with all the
formal dancing [ __ ]
where it's like husband and wife oh yeah
that's all great we all love that
yeah father-daughter great love that
you know daughter or our son
mom fine whatever if we have to yeah
okay and then like oh wedding party
dance oh my god it's taking forever
you mean like rooms first yeah the best
best man
and the good bridesmaids like we [ __ ]
got it
yeah when does everyone else get the
[ __ ] damn oh are you a dancer is that
why you're like you're one of those
people will come in and
oh he did you bust it open i go hard
bless it open
down i started i started a full-on
movement
i was like we're [ __ ] dancing because
everyone was getting restless and i was
like we're [ __ ] dancing out here
and so we [ __ ] started dancing like
out with the tables and [ __ ] we're
[ __ ] going
we're [ __ ] dancing and [ __ ] and were
they like [ __ ] steve man
no they were everyone there was a lot of
the the the
no the wedding gave in because we're
like we get it yeah like we can feel the
crowd
which is good but my god whose genius
idea was to do that though
first probably like traditionally it was
true because like freaking siennas for
example that's how it goes like you
dance with your mother he knows your
padre knows like
you're into the sabrinas now you're
making stuff up
the mc wasn't moving along they're
supposed to it was like between
dances or six minutes and you're like
what the [ __ ] guys like it was like that
so like the crowd was like yo
i said madrinos it's madrinas anyway
i know what you mean i know what you
mean mandarinas i like that quinceanera
video where the mom's singing to the
daughter and
like it's horrible oh yeah and she's
just standing there
it sounds like that and she's about to
crack the [ __ ] up
yeah it's a real good video dang i miss
those parties like
same here really big vibrant lively
parties but coven
you know this one was like super
intimate there was like my neighbors
still do them so that's good
they don't care they sure don't do they
get their water shut off
uh no oh yeah that's the l.a thing yeah
did they stop doing that are they still
doing that i think they stopped like
mansion parties and stuff
yeah it was for like a hot minute for
all those like tick tockers
oh yeah turn their water off turn their
water off you know we have the lowest
uh covid cases in the state now in the
states
california i think we were like hitting
number one yeah
now it's like the lowest it's crazy
cause everyone already got it
and i called it i called it i was like
by june we're gonna open it up
newsome just yeah june 15th right in
june
like everything is fully over i don't
trust them anymore though so i gotta
wear a mask though because that's not
the same you probably still have to do
yeah like in texas they're they're not
like requiring mass but then individual
businesses are like not put your mask on
because i can't wait to work out without
a mask i know i can't wait man
wearing a mask is kind of rough these
days when they're working out it's going
to be in the eyes yeah dude
vaccine passports now so like people
that have
like a vaccine they could just travel
freely to countries that accept it
wow yeah both shots are just the first
i don't know what the process is but
there's now like
like government cards that that says
vaccine passport
whatever yeah there are people who are
very upset about that
why uh vaccine passports because uh a
lot of people are saying like well
this is the start to a slippery slope
like should we be vaccinated for
absolutely everything
in order to travel so a lot of people
don't like that it's like infringing on
their
right that's true i got my tetanus shots
how about that
yeah i'll be like i got my bubonic
plague shots
that's pretty controversial joe so don't
even talk does that mean we can't travel
unless we get the vaccine i think in
certain countries
well can you just like skip kind of like
getting into cuba through mexico kind of
thing like can you do that
maybe you just gotta find a chinese guy
i'll figure it out yeah
here's your choice
they're going to have covered coyotes
now it's like yo man i'm trying to get
into germany he goes i got the perfect
place
now it's going to be like a texan and a
cowboy hat cowboy boo's like i can get
you in right
damn this is crazy everything is like
all weird now but then the coyote is
like hey um
yeah i just need you to take this shot
real quick i'll get you through it
i know it's illegal so this is gotta
take a sexy
this isn't that shot it's difficult oh
by the way wear your mask while we're
going for you yeah yeah
you're gonna feel body aches afterwards
for about 24 hours you'll be fine
it's not don't worry it's not the cold
it's not the kovid relax i do miss
regular life though i really miss it i
miss being able to just
what do you miss the most the most movie
theaters yeah
yeah theater is kind of back though like
limited streams
the whole time so pretty rough i'm just
chilling
and stuff then if you're there well you
remove your mask when you eat the
popcorn you put your mask back on main
rules whereas like
minimize the amount of times okay i miss
not wearing a mask indoors
in a public space that's what i miss the
most
that's what i truly miss i like corona
you like it
where do you like it i just don't like
the traveling part of it yeah yeah
i like how everyone's um not out in the
streets and driving
and i can't have jobs and like a lot of
people i
i like how people are struggling
that's what you meant right joe that's
what you meant no you took it there
but i think la's overcrowded too i feel
like the traffic is back though
dude the traffic oh yeah it's been bad
dude but i gotta say
it's still not as bad as what it was
it's just not yes it is back
traffic period is back but not what it
was yeah how long did it get
i mean what it was was like from five to
eight p.m
it takes an hour to go how long was it
for you to get here today
took me half hour so in the past it was
an hour
every [ __ ] time it was an hour hour
20 hours peak pandemic
how long did it take 10 minutes eight
minutes
[ __ ] yeah 15 minutes 15 minutes on
average when it was a ghost town outside
i remember i reminisce about like early
cover days where it just you look
outside
no one's out there and i'm like oh man
we were freaking out we thought it was
like a zombie apocalypse yeah but
yeah i was scared there were the
beginning yeah i was scared there was a
face
like the tanks oh yeah that was [ __ ]
scary after all of it i got here from my
house in 17 minutes that's amazing
obeying the speed limit yeah that's what
i'm saying is an
unbelievable experience the amount of
like idiots that are on the road now
versus like yes in summer last year
yup it's incredible unfortunately the
idiots did not die
i was hoping we thought they would yeah
we really did because we said you know
what
oh they're gonna do stupid [ __ ] oh
they're gonna go out to the store not
wear a mask all the [ __ ]
no i didn't die and still they would
still do it and nothing happened
nothing nothing at all they got a
headache for three days
yeah and they were like they kind of
taste their food they were like
nothing [ __ ] jerk off it even more
why couldn't china have sent us a
deadlier violence
that's what we're trying to create
better that's what this man was trying
to say the thousands of deaths
according to the statistics so a lot of
people but the good ones had to go
that's what we're saying sweet little
old people nice people
you know harmless sick people you know
overweight people i know they're just
jolly
take out the ones that we don't want yes
like the squatters aggressive drivers
yeah but not my friend bart yeah but
other aggressive guys yeah
i don't see waters that don't have fat
asses yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you